Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Speaking of psychology is a podcast for anyone with an interest in the science of psychology. We talk to psychological researchers, practitioners, and educators about any and every aspect of psychology and its application to the world around us. Dr. Jeff Hancock is founding director of the Stanford Social Media Lab and a professor in the Department of Communication at Stanford University. Dr. Hancock works on understanding psychological and interpersonal processes in social media. His research team specializes in using computational linguistics and experiments to understand how the words we use can reveal psychological and social dynamics such as deception, trust, intimacy, and social support.
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人金·米尔斯。《心理学谈话》是为所有对心理学科学感兴趣的人准备的播客。我们与心理学研究人员、从业者和教育工作者探讨心理学的方方面面及其在现实世界中的应用。杰夫·汉考克博士是斯坦福大学社交媒体实验室的创始主任，也是斯坦福大学传播系的教授。汉考克博士致力于研究社交媒体中的心理和人际交往过程。他的研究团队专门利用计算语言学和实验来理解我们使用的词汇如何揭示心理和社会动态，例如欺骗、信任、亲密关系和社会支持。
Dr. Hancock is well known for his research on how people use deception with technology from sending texts and emails to detecting fake online reviews. We're fortunate to have him here today with the American Psychological Association. Welcome, Dr. Hancock. Thank you, Kim. So I wanted to start by talking a little bit about social robots and your work in that arena. The first question is just to explain for the audience what's a social robot as opposed to any other robot. Right, right.
汉考克博士因其关于人们如何利用技术进行欺骗的研究而闻名，从发送短信和电子邮件到检测虚假在线评论。我们很荣幸今天能请到他来到美国心理学会。欢迎您，汉考克博士。谢谢你，金。我想先谈谈社交机器人以及您在该领域的工作。第一个问题是，请为听众解释一下什么是社交机器人，它与其他机器人有什么区别。对，没错。
Yeah, social robot is really broadly defined. basically any robot that's situated with humans. So a couple of definitions are that they should be socially evocative, sociable. So any robot that's designed to essentially work or interact or evoke responses from humans. So it's not a Roomba, for example. Well, you know, it's funny you should ask that. Rumba is a good question, and our group thought a lot about that. Sometimes a Roomba could be made into a social robot.
是的，社交机器人的定义非常广泛。基本上，任何与人类共处的机器人都可以称为社交机器人。一些定义认为它们应该是能引起社交共鸣的、善于社交的。因此，任何旨在与人类工作、互动或引起人类反应的机器人都可以算作社交机器人。例如，它不是扫地机器人。嗯，你知道，你问这个问题很有趣。扫地机器人是个好问题，我们团队对此思考了很多。有时扫地机器人也可以被改造成社交机器人。
You put some little things on it, and amazingly, people will really interact with that robot as if it's, you know, interacting with them. Get that in the corner there. Exactly. Yeah, come on. Get that work done for me. But no, typically it's robots that are designed to interact with the humans. So it can be in workplaces. So factories now often have robots. And a number of them now have been sort of personalized, made a little bit more human
你在它上面放一些小东西，令人惊讶的是，人们真的会像与它互动一样与那个机器人互动。把它弄到那个角落里。没错。是的，来吧。帮我把那活儿干了。但通常情况下，社交机器人是指那些旨在与人类互动的机器人。所以它可以在工作场所使用。现在的工厂里经常有机器人。其中一些现在已经进行了某种程度的个性化处理，变得更人性化了一些，
so that the workers around them can understand what the robots doing, what its intentions are, where its attention is. So talk a little bit. bit about the research that you did. I understand you looked at like the last decade of all the research that involves social robots. What were you looking for? What did you find? Right. So the group I was working with was Byron Reeves and Sunny Liu, both at Stanford with me. And we had a group of 10 RAs work on this project where we looked at a decade worth of research on social robots. And it was fascinating. And a lot of work. There was almost 7,000 articles in Google
这样周围的工人就能理解机器人在做什么，它的意图是什么，它的注意力在哪里。那么，谈谈你所做的研究吧。据我了解，你研究了过去十年所有涉及社交机器人的研究。你在寻找什么？你发现了什么？好的。我和我一起工作的团队是斯坦福大学的拜伦·里夫斯和桑尼·刘。我们有一个由10名研究助理组成的团队来开展这个项目，我们回顾了过去十年关于社交机器人的研究。这非常引人入胜，而且工作量很大。在谷歌学术上，有近7000篇文章提到了社交机器人。
scholar that referenced social robots. And then we narrowed that down to a about 1400 that mentioned social robots but then also had a robot interacting with a human or looking for some sort of social response. So there's been, you know, over a thousand articles on social robots and it's across a dizzying array of disciplines. So psychologists, computer scientists, engineers, anthropologists, it's pretty amazing. So we looked at all of those across a decade. And then the thing we got really excited about was we found the photo of every robot that was in that decade's worth of work and found as many photos as we could for each robot.
然后我们将范围缩小到大约1400篇，这些文章不仅提到了社交机器人，而且还涉及机器人与人类的互动或寻求某种社交反应。所以，关于社交机器人的文章已经超过一千篇了，而且涉及的学科非常广泛。心理学家、计算机科学家、工程师、人类学家，这真是太神奇了。所以我们回顾了过去十年中所有的这些研究。然后让我们感到非常兴奋的是，我们找到了那十年研究中出现的每一个机器人的照片，并为每个机器人找到了尽可能多的照片。
And so we sort of had like an early census, if you will, of every social robot that had been published about. And it turns out there's 342 that we found over that decade. So there was sort of like one of the first collections of all social. robots that's been put together. And what were you trying to find by looking at that? Well, my colleague Byron Reeves, had this insight when we first started on the project, and one of the reasons I got involved, so I usually study things like social media,
所以我们算是进行了一次早期普查，如果你愿意的话，是对所有发表过的社交机器人进行的普查。结果发现，我们在那十年里找到了342个。所以这算是第一个汇集了所有社交机器人的合集。你通过观察这些试图发现什么？嗯，我的同事拜伦·里夫斯在项目刚开始时就有这个洞察，这也是我参与的原因之一，因为我通常研究社交媒体之类的事物，
so how people interact through technology. But I remember having a great meeting with Byron where he had this insight, which was that we can think of robots as media. And since they're social robots, it was like a form of social media. So I got really excited, and it was really my first big foray into working with robots. And it was all because of Byron's insight of thinking of them as media. And what follows from his insight then is most of the research on social robots looks at one robot at a time. There's a good reason for that.
也就是人们如何通过技术进行互动。但我记得和拜伦开过一次很棒的会议，他提出了一个洞察，那就是我们可以把机器人看作媒体。既然它们是社交机器人，那它就像是一种社交媒体。所以我非常兴奋，这确实是我第一次大规模涉足机器人研究。这一切都归功于拜伦将它们视为媒体的洞察。随之而来的问题是，大多数关于社交机器人的研究一次只看一个机器人。这有很好的理由。
They're expensive. Usually you've built a robot, and you want to understand, you know, how does this robot evoke a response? Is it effective at getting people to learn or to feel better if it's in assistive context? The problem with that, which we know from psychology, is if you're trying to generalize to social robots, studying one robot at a time is a real problem. This is a problem of stimulus sampling. And so in psychology, we've known about this issue for many decades since the middle of the last century. What Byron's insight sort of led to is that we need to get a big collection of these stimuli
它们很昂贵。通常你造了一个机器人，你想了解，你知道，这个机器人是如何引起反应的？如果它在辅助环境中，它在让人们学习或感觉更好方面有效吗？从心理学角度来看，这样做的问题在于，如果你试图推广到社交机器人，一次研究一个机器人是一个真正的问题。这是一个刺激抽样的问题。在心理学中，自上世纪中叶以来的几十年里，我们一直了解这个问题。拜伦的洞察力引导我们意识到，我们需要收集大量的这些刺激，
so that we can start generalizing across social robots as a category of social actor rather than, well, does this robot do anything? Or if we make this robot have an arm versus no arm, does it do anything? And so that was what we were interested in, is getting this big collection together so we could start doing research on a population, a sample, if you will, of social robots, rather than one exemplar at a time. And so what does this portend for the future? How will this be applied?
这样我们就可以开始在社交机器人作为一个社交行为者类别上进行概括，而不是仅仅关注“这个机器人做了什么？”或者“如果我们给这个机器人装上手臂而不是不装手臂，它会做什么？”所以这就是我们感兴趣的地方，收集这些大量的样本，这样我们就可以开始对社交机器人的人群或样本进行研究，而不是一次只研究一个范例。那么这对未来意味着什么？这将如何应用？
Right. That's the key question. And it's been exciting at this conference because I've already talked to, you know, half a dozen people that came up after the talk that were like, hey, we'd like to do this project or that project. What we've done is started by asking, well, now that we have this collection of robots
对。这是关键问题。在这个会议上，我感到很兴奋，因为我已经和半打在演讲后走过来的人聊过了，他们说，嘿，我们想做这个项目或那个项目。我们所做的是从提问开始，好吧，既然我们有了这些机器人的合集，
and a collection of photos of them, you know, when you look at them and, I can share an image with you to go on the podcast or a website. It's astonishing how varied they are. I mean, even when we show it to people that are in the field and have been in the field for a decade, they're like, whoa, okay, these are really, really different. I mean, it's sort of like thinking, you know, I could take you and study you as an example of an extrovert and then, you know, journalized to all the extroverts, but we know that
以及它们的照片合集，你知道，当你看着它们时，我可以分享一张图片给你，放在播客或网站上。它们的多样性令人震惊。我的意思是，即使我们向该领域的人展示，即使是那些已经在该领域工作了十年的人，他们也会说，哇，好吧，这些真的非常非常不同。我的意思是，这就像是认为，我可以把你作为外向者的例子来研究，然后推广到所有的外向者，但我们知道，
people are really different. Well, robots are even more different than different people. So the first question then is, do we need a whole new psychology, a whole new psychology, understand social responses to social robots? And the answer, when we look at the literature, is pretty clearly no. People tend to bring sort of standard social psychological processes to new media. So there's tons of work that shows that we treat technology. kind of as social actors. And we bring our old brain, which has been evolving for a long time to understand
人与人之间真的非常不同。那么第一个问题是，我们需要一套全新的心理学来理解对社交机器人的社交反应吗？当我们查看文献时，答案很明显是否定的。人们倾向于将某种标准的社会心理过程带入新媒体。因此，有大量的研究表明，我们对待技术就像对待社交行为者一样。我们带着我们的大脑，它为了理解社交行为者已经进化了很长时间，
social actors, like, you know, is this a friend or a foe? We bring that to technology. So the next question then is, well, if we don't need a new psychology, because people, you know, sort of react and perceive technology the same way they do humans, what's a good place to start to look at, you know, is there a fundamental dimension or two in which people perceive robots? When we looked at the In the literature in social psychology around person perception, there's a lot of evidence that people judge others along two dimensions very quickly, automatically, and comprehensively. So their warmth and competence. And some of the main research on this are Susan Fiske and her colleagues, Amy Cuddy, for example. they've done a tremendous amount of work showing that over, you know, 100 years of research
比如，这是朋友还是敌人？我们把这种认知带到了技术上。所以下一个问题是，如果我们不需要一套新的心理学，因为人们对技术的反应和感知方式与对人类相同，那么从哪里开始寻找比较好呢？人们感知机器人是否存在一两个基本维度？当我们查看社会心理学中关于人际感知的文献时，有大量证据表明，人们非常迅速、自动且全面地从两个维度来判断他人。即温暖和能力。这方面的一些主要研究者是苏珊·菲斯克和她的同事，例如艾米·卡迪。他们做了大量的工作，表明在100年的研究中，
across cultures, people's perceptions, initial perceptions of other people really boil down to warmth. So is this person going to be trustworthy kind warm towards me or are they cold, perhaps, threatening? And they argue this is an evolutionary question. Is this a friend or a foe? I need to determine that right away. and then another is competence.
跨越不同文化，人们对他人的初步感知确实归结为温暖。所以，这个人是值得信赖的、友善的、对我温暖的，还是冷漠的，甚至是威胁性的？他们认为这是一个进化问题。这是朋友还是敌人？我需要立刻确定这一点。然后另一个是能力。
So does this person seem capable, competitive, strong, these sort of terms? And so we thought, let's start there. Let's take a look at that. And what we did is we had several thousand, over 3,000 mechanical Turk participants. Take a look at a single robot and then answer a bunch of questions like, does this person, this robot seem warm or cold, a bunch of those. A bunch of ones related to competence or not. And then we did what, you know, psychological researchers do.
所以这个人看起来有能力、有竞争力、强大吗？诸如此类。所以我们想，让我们从这里开始。让我们看一看。我们所做的是让几千名，超过3000名亚马逊土耳其机器人的参与者，看一个单一的机器人，然后回答一堆问题，比如，这个人，这个机器人看起来温暖还是冷漠，诸如此类。一堆与能力相关的问题。然后我们做了心理学研究人员通常做的事情。
You factor analyze those to see if they resolve to some factors. And it's amazing, Kim, it's exactly the same as if we show them. Just like people? So what makes a robot warm or cold? Ah, right. So that was our next question. Exactly. Because designers are going to want to know this, right?
你对这些进行因子分析，看看它们是否能归结为某些因子。金，这太神奇了，结果和我们展示给他们看的一模一样。就像对待人一样？那么是什么让机器人显得温暖或冷漠呢？啊，对。那是我们的下一个问题。没错。因为设计师会想知道这一点，对吧？
Like, how do I make it warm or cold or competent or incompetent? warmth, it turns out, is really driven by eyes. So does it have eyes or not? Which you wouldn't normally think of right away. But they don't. I mean, G-GBO doesn't have eyes, for example. Right, exactly, exactly. So that's a major thing.
比如，我该如何让它显得温暖或冷漠，或者有能力或无能？事实证明，温暖感确实是由眼睛驱动的。所以它是否有眼睛？你通常不会立刻想到这一点。但它们没有。我的意思是，例如Gebo就没有眼睛。对，没错，没错。所以这是一个主要因素。
And not only anything about eyes. So once you have eyes, that's a big predictor. Then it's the ratio of the eye size to your head size. And there's lots of evidence that this is about warmth too. Disney characters, for example, tend to have really big eyes. Really eyes. Yeah. So that's a really huge factor.
而且不仅仅是关于眼睛。一旦你有眼睛，那就是一个很大的预测指标。然后是眼睛大小与头部大小的比例。有大量证据表明这也与温暖有关。例如，迪士尼角色往往有非常大的眼睛。真的眼睛。是的。所以这是一个非常巨大的因素。
And then in terms of competence, it's the lack of fur. So if you can see the mechanics, you know, like steel and, you know, actuators and stuff of that, they're going to actually appear more competent. If there's fur, they're going to appear less competent. And then mobility is a big one for competence. If that thing can move around, whether it's arms or moving around like that, then there's more competence. And so it's amazing. And it actually has really fascinating and potentially disturbing implications.
至于能力，则是缺乏皮毛。所以如果你能看到机械结构，你知道，比如钢材、执行器之类的东西，它们实际上会显得更有能力。如果有皮毛，它们会显得能力较弱。而移动性是能力的一个重要指标。如果那个东西能四处走动，无论是手臂还是像那样移动，那么它就更有能力。这太神奇了。而且它确实有非常迷人且可能令人不安的含义。
So Fisk and her colleagues have this model called the stereotype content model. And they say with warmth and competence, you can kind of predict in this 2D space stereotypes. So competent, competent is up in the right. those are people that are, sorry, high warm, high competent. And that's the default in-group. So when they were doing their research in the early 2000s, late 90s, this would be like white middle-class America. So if you ask Americans at that time, you know,
菲斯克和她的同事有一个模型叫刻板印象内容模型。他们说，有了温暖和能力，你可以在这个二维空间中预测刻板印象。所以，高能力、高温暖在右上角。那些是，抱歉，高温暖、高能力。那是默认的内群体。所以当他们在2000年代初、90年代末进行研究时，这就像是美国白人中产阶级。所以如果你当时问美国人，你知道，
the default group, the high-competence, high-warmth, that was white middle-class America. And you go down into the lower space where it's high-competence, low-warmth, these are like engineers, rich people. And these people are, they evoke a difference. different kind of emotion. So it's envy, right? So in a little bit, so you like, you admire them a little bit, but it's more like a little suspicious. So they evoke this, this envy thing. Whereas the default group evokes like admiration and positive emotions. You keep going around, so you're
默认群体，高能力、高温暖，那就是美国白人中产阶级。当你进入高能力、低温暖的下层空间时，这些就像是工程师、富人。这些人，他们引起了一种不同的情绪。所以是嫉妒，对吧？所以有一点，你有点钦佩他们，但更多的是有点怀疑。所以他们引起了这种嫉妒感。而默认群体引起的是钦佩和积极的情绪。你继续绕圈，所以你
down to the low, low space, and stereotypes down there would be poor people. So this would be poor white, poor black, homeless, people on welfare. And, um, and, um, And they evoke a different kind of emotion as well, which is contempt. And so you keep going around, you get up to the high, warmth, low competence. These are people in the 90s would be like housewives, people in that sort of space, you know, mentally handicapped individuals, you know. So again, these are stereotypes. Yeah.
到了低温暖、低能力的区域，那里的刻板印象会是穷人。这可能是贫穷的白人、贫穷的黑人、无家可归者、领取福利的人。而且，他们也引起了一种不同的情绪，那就是蔑视。所以你继续绕圈，你会到达高温暖、低能力。在90年代，这些人会是家庭主妇，处于那种空间的人，你知道，智力残疾的人，你知道。所以再次强调，这些是刻板印象。是的。
And the emotion to evoke there is pity. So as a designer, if you're designing a robot with these different features, unbeknownst to you, you could actually be causing an initial emotional response that is deep-seated in our psychology. That's pretty interesting. Yeah, we thought so. So, does this research tie in at all with the work that you're doing on deception? Yeah, so now we're doing a bunch of things about like trust of robots. So how much would you trust this robot?
而那里引起的情绪是怜悯。所以作为一名设计师，如果你设计一个带有这些不同特征的机器人，你可能在不知不觉中引起了一种在我们心理中根深蒂固的初步情绪反应。这很有趣。是的，我们也这么认为。那么，这项研究与你正在做的关于欺骗的研究有任何联系吗？是的，所以我们现在正在做很多关于机器人信任的事情。所以你会多大程度上信任这个机器人？
and the initial work there is, you know, warmth is going to be a big predictor of that, your sense of its status. But then we'll need to move it into different kinds of situations. So I might trust Gebo in a interpersonal interaction where we're just having a fun social interaction. But I might not trust Gebo if I'm on the battlefield and I need a robot to help me find bombs and diffuse them, right? So situations are going to play a really huge role. and our collection of photos really is in sort of a totally neutral, like there's zero context. So that's the next step.
初步的研究是，你知道，温暖将是一个很大的预测指标，你对它地位的感觉。但我们需要将其转移到不同类型的情况中。所以我可能会在人际互动中信任Gebo，我们只是在进行有趣的社交互动。但如果我在战场上，我需要一个机器人帮我寻找炸弹并拆除它们，我可能就不会信任Gebo，对吧？所以情况将发挥非常巨大的作用。而我们的照片合集确实处于一种完全中立的状态，没有任何背景。所以这是下一步。
But yeah, I'm really interested in deception with these robots. You know, one of my favorite examples of deception with technology wasn't a robot, but kind of similar. And that's the Volkswagen scandal where they program their cars to lie to investigators who were looking for, like, how much pollution it would produce. Right. So it's fascinating. This car, when it figured out that it was being tested, changed its behavior, right? Like, it would literally have less power but produce fewer emissions, and not one car. Millions of these.
但是是的，我对这些机器人的欺骗行为非常感兴趣。你知道，我最喜欢的关于技术欺骗的例子之一不是机器人，但有点类似。那就是大众汽车丑闻，他们对汽车进行编程，以欺骗那些调查其排放量的调查人员。对。所以这很迷人。这辆车在发现自己被测试时，改变了它的行为，对吧？它实际上会减少动力但产生更少的排放，而且不是一辆车。是数百万辆。
And programmed to lie to humans. And so, I mean, it's really fascinating. And so you know the engineers used robotics when they were developing this? Well, we don't know that, but we can kind of think of the car a little bit like a robot, right? It's a technology that it wasn't. making its own decision, it was programmed in, but it was programmed by humans to lie to humans via, you know, its sort of technology. So, right, what's going to happen with robots? We've seen some autonomous robots that have learned to lie. So these are small little robots, and their
并且被编程为欺骗人类。所以，我的意思是，这真的很迷人。你知道工程师在开发这个时使用了机器人技术吗？嗯，我们不知道，但我们可以把车看作有点像机器人，对吧？它是一种技术，它不是在做自己的决定，它是被编程的，但它是被人类编程来通过其技术欺骗人类。所以，对，机器人会发生什么？我们已经看到一些自主机器人学会了撒谎。所以这些是小机器人，它们的
job is to go around and find food, and they're competing with other little robots, and the food is like a little electrical charge that they get. And they are given some artificial intelligence, so they're trying to find food but not let their other robots get the food. And these robots would learn to lie. They would go to an area. Once they found where the electricity was, they would then go to another area and buzz around there. And then other robots would come, and when they all came there, you're going. And we see this with animals.
工作是四处寻找食物，它们在与其他小机器人竞争，食物就像它们获得的一点电荷。它们被赋予了一些人工智能，所以它们试图寻找食物但不让其他机器人得到食物。这些机器人会学会撒谎。它们会去一个区域。一旦它们发现电力在哪里，它们就会去另一个区域并在那里嗡嗡作响。然后其他机器人会过来，当它们都过来时，你就走了。我们在动物身上也看到了这一点。
Like crows are very good at doing deception. So a younger male crow that will get beat up by the higher status crow will pretend to find food somewhere. And then when all the big crows come, it goes off to where that. Right, right. So, right. So we're seeing humans using technology like robots to lie to other humans. And we're seeing some of the very earliest evolution of deception in these sort of artificial intelligence systems. Were those robots actually programmed to learn deception?
比如乌鸦非常擅长欺骗。所以一只会被地位更高的乌鸦欺负的年轻雄性乌鸦会假装在某处找到食物。然后当所有的大乌鸦过来时，它就去了别的地方。对，对。所以，对。我们看到人类利用机器人这样的技术来欺骗其他人。我们也看到这些人工智能系统中出现了最早的欺骗进化。那些机器人真的被编程来学习欺骗吗？
So they just... They were given these constraints and objectives. And the objective was to get as much of this food, their electricity as possible. and that they were competing with these other robots. And so from that, they learned that deception was a good tactic to do. And we see this with non-physical AI, so things like chatbots, conversational AI, in a negotiation game where they're negotiating with another human or with a human or with another AI, we saw that deception, that same kind of idea of deceiving evolved in that as well.
所以它们只是……它们被赋予了这些约束和目标。目标是尽可能多地获得这种食物，它们的电力。而且它们在与其他机器人竞争。因此，它们学会了欺骗是一种很好的策略。我们在非物理人工智能中也看到了这一点，比如聊天机器人、对话式人工智能，在谈判游戏中，当它们与另一个人或与人类或与另一个人造智能谈判时，我们看到欺骗，那种欺骗的想法也在其中进化了。
So it's pretty clearly an advantageous evolutionary strategy. Once you're able to communicate something that isn't necessarily true, then deception becomes a strategy for achieving your goals. It comes with risks. So if you're having a one-off interaction with another person where you're trying to get goods from them, then deception can be very useful. But over the long term, deception has been shown to not be
所以这显然是一种有利的进化策略。一旦你能够传达一些不一定真实的东西，那么欺骗就成为实现你目标的一种策略。它伴随着风险。所以如果你与另一个人进行一次性互动，试图从他们那里获得商品，那么欺骗可能非常有用。但从长远来看，欺骗已被证明不一定是
necessarily the best strategy. Are we moving in any particular direction around the design of robots? I mean, I'm thinking, are they going to become more human-like, less human-like, or does it really depend on the context? Yeah, I mean, that's a really great question. And I think Justine Kassel, who did the keynote yesterday, I think sort of like re-asked that question, which was, it's not about what the robots or these conversational agents and their humanness necessarily,
最好的策略。我们在机器人设计方面是否朝着任何特定的方向发展？我的意思是，我在想，它们会变得更像人，更不像人，还是真的取决于环境？是的，我的意思是，这是一个非常好的问题。我认为昨天做主题演讲的贾斯汀·卡塞尔，我认为重新提出了那个问题，即，这不一定关乎机器人或这些对话代理及其人性，
but rather about our humanness. And so she really put us into this concept of intersubjectivity, which is when I feel like I'm engaging with the technology and I'm doing that as a human and I'm having a very human interaction, then whatever that agent is is a success in that regard. So it's about creating a sense of intersubjectivity. And I thought that was a really nice way of asking. the question because then they can be human-like and they can be machine-like but
而是关乎我们的人性。所以她确实把我们带入了主体间性的概念，即当我感觉我正在与技术互动，并且我作为一个人在这样做，并且我正在进行非常人性化的互动时，那么无论那个代理是什么，它在这方面都是成功的。所以这是关于创造一种主体间性的感觉。我认为这是一个非常好的提问方式，因为它们可以是像人的，也可以是像机器的，但
it's going to be about how that sort of diatic interaction works so I think it's you know one of my intellectual heroes is is Herb Clark who's also at Stanford and and his work shows that a lot of conversation and interaction communication is really tightly coupled it's a joint action so what we're doing right now is very joint. So we're nodding each other and we're agreeing and swamped the right time and looking. And I know I'm in a very human activity, right? This is this amazing joint activity of communication. And so that's what's going to matter, I think, with robots and with, you know, AI-type technologies is the degree to which they're coordinating with us and and building up that intersubjectivity. So they could look kind of artificial still machine-like and still relate to them in a warm way.
这将取决于那种二元互动是如何运作的。所以我认为，你知道，我的智力英雄之一是赫伯·克拉克，他也在斯坦福大学，他的研究表明，大量的对话和互动交流是紧密耦合的，这是一种联合行动。所以我们现在正在做的事情是非常联合的。所以我们在点头，我们在同意，在正确的时间交换意见，并且在注视。我知道我正在进行一项非常人性化的活动，对吧？这是这种惊人的联合交流活动。所以这就是我认为机器人和人工智能技术所重要的，即它们与我们协调并建立那种主体间性的程度。所以它们看起来仍然可能有点人工、像机器，但仍然可以以温暖的方式与它们建立联系。
Right. Cynthia Brazel's G-Bo, and she gave the first keynote here, doesn't look human at all. But people really react to it, right? Yeah, the video she showed was amazing. It's very evocative, right? And they're having this pleasant and intriguing and surprising kind of interaction. And there's zero, you know, appearance of humanness. but Gibo has this ability to sense and respond in a way that feels very abock.
对。辛西娅·布雷泽尔的Gebo，她在这里做了第一次主题演讲，看起来一点也不像人。但人们确实对它有反应，对吧？是的，她展示的视频太棒了。它非常引人入胜，对吧？它们正在进行这种愉快、有趣和令人惊讶的互动。而且完全没有，你知道，人性的外表。但Gebo有一种感知和反应的能力，感觉非常像人。
I mean, it's kind of like, you know, people love dogs, right? And they don't look human at all. But, you know, people form these really deep bonds with them. And it's because of that sense of intersubjectivity. Well, it's very interesting. Yeah. Thank you so much for being with us today. My pleasure, Kim.
我的意思是，这有点像，你知道，人们喜欢狗，对吧？它们看起来一点也不像人。但是，你知道，人们与它们建立了非常深厚的联系。这是因为那种主体间性的感觉。嗯，这非常有趣。是的。非常感谢您今天来到这里。我的荣幸，金。
I really enjoyed it. Speaking of psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts such as APA. APA Journal's dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research, and progress notes, which discusses the practice of psychology. You can find all APA podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, Speakingof Psychology.org, to listen to more episodes and see more resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我真的很喜欢。 《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他很棒的播客，例如APA。APA期刊对话关于最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究，以及进展笔记，讨论心理学的实践。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到所有APA播客。您也可以访问我们的网站SpeakingofPsychology.org，收听更多剧集并查看有关我们讨论主题的更多资源。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯，这是《心理学谈话》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。